what's up you beautiful little cinnamon
architects I'm Theo von and I'm really
excited to announce that I am starting a
patreon page for my podcast this past
weekend that's the sign I started this
past weekend about nine months ago as a
way to share and connect with you
through personal stories I slept in a
ball pit one night I'm just gonna put my
penis into somebody's mouth that I
barely know I buy groceries and I'd hung
them out the window during the day
because it was freezing outside current
events Pizza gate you know they name it
Harvey and that's what I like about some
of these storms California supposed to
be in a drought here the dams gonna
break like pick your poison mental doing
my bests just a little bit of everything
including call ins from you guys I'm
calling you today to ask you about
advice I got those thing down the block
ago yeah and we need to do something
with that [ __ ] right we had to up
our level of communication and stop
making so many assumptions everyone I'm
with since I can't stop thinking about
my ex-wife and and we can you know just
kind of be a part of everything together
and I gotta say that this whole
experience has been astounding I love
doing the show I love connecting with
you guys and I want to be able to keep
doing it and I want to be able to take
the show to a higher level and to then a
higher higher level got big ambitions
with this cat that brings me to why I'm
wearing this clean shirt I'm about to
ask you for money
the best way I've found for people to
directly donate to the show which a lot
of people have asked about is through a
platform called patreon well patreon is
a platform or program that allows you to
personally donate to the show in
exchange for some pretty you know sick
dick ulis and specific and special
rewards and tears of return for $2 a
month you get to be a supporter thank
you I appreciate it every little bit
helps and I sincerely mean that for $5
you get to be an even more gracious
supporter $5 supporters will have access
to a patreon or patreon page where they
can experience behind-the-scenes footage
an extra episode maybe an AMA something
each month and as often as I can that is
specific to that level of support and
that has to do mostly with this past
weekend sometimes stand-up just
different aspects of whatever's going on
in the near future I'll be adding even
higher levels of straight-up sweet glory
where people can really get involved and
become a straight-up glorified
Guatemalan skunk touch her like myself
you know and I don't know what those
will be yet but I want them to make them
you I want to make them unique I want to
make them unique and effective and make
people feel if they if they donate at
other levels that they're really
becoming part of the show or getting a
reward that they feel is of value I
appreciate anybody's support whether you
choose to help support through patreon
or not I appreciate it I just want you
no matter what to just continue
supporting this past weekend I want you
no matter what to go to youtube if you
have constructive criticisms
constructive and hit me up let me know
what you think
email me Theo von at matcom let me know
what you think I can do to help be a
liaison to make this show and this
experience better we're just getting
started and I promise to show up here
every week and do my best and put my
best foot forward and I just you know
I'd love your support in any way that
you can so if that means just continuing
to watch thank you if that means
fiscally supporting thank you if that
means rolling out constructive criticism
or telling a friend about the podcast
gracias
so check out patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]